love this guy he's been on the show many
many times this show is on my house
on a television in my house literally
like it's the sports version of law and
order quite frankly like it's on
all the time it's on somewhere on some
nbc family of networks
and season 13 of nbc's american ninja
warrior premieres
on memorial day night at eight eastern
time every single monday after that for
a new episode at eight
eastern and pacific and you can catch up
on past episodes of american ninja
warrior
on peacock back here on the rich eyes
and show matt iceman how are you matt
oh rich i am sitting here with the
biggest smile on my face after listening
to that 30
30. honestly that is gonna go down like
the synchronized swimming sketch from
saturday night live in my book
just one of those ones that i could
watch again and again find new reasons
to laugh every time
i mean akbar's first pitch is our fake
30 for 30 because
i mean seriously he he made 50 cent look
like nolan ryan i mean
you know what it's like too when you
work with nfl players they constantly
remind you
they were nfl players and you weren't
and i get that
non-stop from him so to see him uh in
his athletic glory
captured uh for for all of time to
remember that
that that one gave me joy it's similar
to i guess falling uh
falling into some sort of water falling
off of uh
falling off one of the many constructs
on your show
and just just face planning except you
know this is far more embarrassing
because at least
because you're expected to have some
sort of physical prowess and then you
come up about 50 feet
short that is nearly killed the fanatic
i
i
mean it was it was something out of bull
durham where he's hitting the mass got
to send a message but
no one knows what that message was it's
kind of like because i know you know
comedy and you know
late night television matt so um it
would be similar to i guess
an uh an american ninja warrior getting
ready to climb that last wall that big
line let big run up to the last wall to
climb up that wall
and then obviously um stop the clock and
and win right um and hit the button to
win
it would be similar to that david
letterman moment where he jumped on the
wall in his velcro suit and just
attached to the wall like that would be
that that slapstick
dave osborne would have been proud of
aquarius right there
the great super dave osborne i forgot
about that one man
how are you doing matt how's how's life
for you everything good doing great
we we just got back we were in las vegas
uh
just wrapping up the season out there
and it was so nice to be back in vegas
and for the first time in a couple years
we started to have uh uh fans in the
stands
that's great and it it's just it's nice
to feel
uh to feel a little bit like the way
things were so i i'm still riding on
cloud nine from that
so this season the age limit to compete
has been lowered to 15 years old so
now my kids are going to start watching
it thinking that they're close they're
getting close they're getting
it they're getting close to being in the
big one as opposed to the the junior
competition that they imagine they could
maybe get in one day
you know and that's it so now the age
you know is nine to fourteen on american
engineer junior
right because they were so good on that
show we thought we're going to let a
couple of them take a shot on our big
course this season
and rich they they've blown us away i
mean
it we knew they had some athletic
ability we we've seen them in their
videos we've seen them tackling
obstacles
but what we didn't know was how they
would handle being on the big stage with
the lights at their brightest
with a million dollars on the line would
they would they rise or would they just
crumble and
thinking back to what i you know when i
was a high school sophomore
akbar and i were talking about this if
you'd had a chance to play
in the league at that point to to go to
the nba or nfl
right you there was no way you were
ready physically but certainly
emotionally
and these athletes have been outstanding
they have been
so strong and they're out there we're
like okay first of all it's past your
bedtime
second of all you should be doing
algebra homework and third you are
absolutely crushing this so
it's been exciting to see the young
bloods coming on there and to feel like
you know this is this is it's really a
reinfusion now this new energy coming
into the show
but my god do i feel old rich you gotta
you got a new do you got a new um
uh obstacle new uh part of the course
that what are you going for
always we always have a a slew of new
obstacles but one of the things we did
this year
was it's called a split decision so
there's an obstacle
uh where in the course the the ninjas
get there and they have a choice
it can be a choice between two different
types of balance obstacles maybe an
upper body optical or a balanced
obstacle
but it becomes choose your own adventure
what's interesting is
ninjas may have different skill sets if
you're a little bigger guy you may think
i'm not going to do upper body i'll
try balance um so we're seeing the
ninjas now
really take their fate into their own
hands because before it's always been
hey
just face whatever's out there and keep
going but now you have to have a little
bit of strategy here
choosing which obstacle you'll think
you'll be successful in and as soon as
people hit the water on that one you see
them going
i chose poorly
instant regret now help me out with this
uh matt iceman here on the rich eisen
show american ninja warrior returns
for season 13 coming up uh in six days
so memorial day
night make sure you make a note on um on
nbc at eight eastern time
um you know i i don't want to stir any
problems up in your workplace matt this
is
this is uh this is my wind up this is my
wine
this is my windup this is my windup but
uh do the producers who come up
with these obstacles do they have a
problem do they
like they literally like seeing people
squirm
um what is what is going on here because
how do they come up with some of this
stuff man
well what's insane is we come up with
these obstacles and very often we'll
we'll they'll send us videos and testing
uh of the obstacles
as they they're kind of going through
iterations and
and i every time i look at nomsa i think
how is anyone
going to ever get through this and
what's amazing is is watching these
athletes because again for those who
aren't familiar with the show
they don't know what they're going to
face until they show up on our course
they don't get to practice you get one
shot on these obstacles
so not only do they have no idea what
they're facing or how to do it
they don't even know what it feels like
or or or how much
strength it's going to require so to see
the problem-solving ability
because we keep upping the difficulty
and we think no one's getting through
this course
and then one person gets through it and
and it's like
it's like the the the when they when
they figure out how to use a stick to
get the ants out of the hole
like all of a sudden everyone starts
emulating it successfully gets success
and all of a sudden we think all right
we got to come up with a harder course
because these guys are figuring it out
i know and then it's just there's it's
kind of like the nfl where they before
they make a rule change they try to
figure out what the unintended
consequence is going to be
you know that's it and it's an arms race
and we are losing
you know it's funny too because again
watching it with my kids they get
um they get invested when the you know
when we meet
one of the ninjas uh up close and
personal to use the old sports
tv phrase right and we we learn about
their journey and then
you know their parents are there
watching and then they're you know
they're cheering on and then you're
you're rooting for this person and they
literally eat it
within the first 10 seconds and i feel
like why did why
i feel like maybe we're being done dirty
you know like my mom
my mom will call me after an episode why
did you make me care about that person
if you knew he was going to fall
i'm sorry mom my kids are like that too
they're like what the hell was that like
they kind of wanted it
it's funny we you know it's always tough
because
we get to know these athletes you know
this is season 13 i've i've i've seen
these people
some of them you know get married have
kids and and watch these families grow
you know how much it means to them and
when they fall you're heartbroken but
you also know
that's why it matters so much that's why
it means so much
when they do hit a buzzer when they do
well because they've fallen because
they've come up short before and it's
it's the stakes it's that idea if you
get one chance at this and
especially heading into the olympic year
when you know we talk about
if you're an nfl player then you you
don't win a super bowl
okay but you know you you probably have
like a seven eight figure salary to go
home to
for these ninjas this is it you know
this is
this is something they they train for
with such passion they dedicate so much
to their lives to it
and so when they come up short you know
how much it stinks but when they do well
you see the joy and it's awesome where
you you realize
this is a moment this is a moment
they'll remember for the rest of their
lives when they're old and gray they'll
think back
i remember when i did that and how good
it felt and and it's awesome
to get to see people have those moments
those life-changing moments
matt eisemann here on the rich island
show okay matt um
you're you're from denver colorado uh
are you
are you expecting aaron rodgers in just
a couple weeks
so we've been given lots of hints to
sean watson we thought it was a landing
spot
aaron rodgers would be great i know drew
locke
um we're hoping for the josh allen you
know turn around in year three but
but i i don't know and and aaron rodgers
i i i which this is this is boggles my
mind that this guy
uh just threw that grenade right back at
him after they gave him jordan love the
year before
uh but if the broncos can can can uh get
him on there because
with mahomes uh and justin herbert in
the chargers the afc west
we we need a qb uh to have a fighting
chance yeah
you could you could use that firepower
in the afc west no
no question about it and i love that you
said the josh allen turn around
in a way would be quite something for
for drew locke i
yeah i i i know so many broncos fans
that are like what do you think do you
think it's possible do you think this
could possibly happen and
you know if it does happen it would have
to happen kind of like the next couple
weeks
like literally this is where the rubber
would beat the road on that it's
it's when peyton manning came in and and
brought us our third super bowl
that felt like a gift and you know now i
don't want to get selfish and see it
happen again but if rogers wants to come
give it
one more shot for a ring man wait i i
think he'd look good in the orange and
blue
i know and so uh jokic we should get him
on your course
we should get him out there don't you
think what an athlete don't you think he
would be
you'd be great i think he's you know
those those long limb basketball players
tend to struggle
but i would love to see him on there i i
mean uh
what he's been doing in the league it's
still a relatively young age
uh it's it he he is an insane athlete
and it's good because
man it feels like since mutumbo was on
the nuggets
since we really had anything to cheer
about back in the 90s what do you think
he would make on his split decision on
an
uh american ninja warrior of course
you see him jump i i think he would
probably just go try to
leap over the entire obstacle uh and
then come up about halfway and realize
you know what i'm a shooter not a dunker
yeah maybe we should get mickelson out
there in the age of 50 and over let's
get mickelson out there
you know let's go phil drinking i want
his fountain of youth because when he's
driving 366 and out driving dee chambeau
at 50. yeah i i tell you what i'm going
out to the course this weekend and i'm
swinging
i'm swinging as hard as i can because
phil has given me hope
you just turned you turned 50 in january
right i did and i
i listen if i hit over 200 yards and it
doesn't snap hook into another fairway i
feel like a victory so
whatever he's drinking is giving him the
george hamilton tan too i mean he's
really working
you know what the shades on the shade's
on giving everybody a thumbs up like
when he was walking through that crowd
literally it now now that i've hit 50 i
don't want to be bothered you know what
i mean like i just state yeah
i need some p just keep your distance
he's just like you know thumbs up
thumbs up point point thumbs up in the
shades and you know
with his george hamilton tan i don't
know what the hell's happening to him
it's amazing
i like it because you remember before he
won a major like the first eight ten
years of his career it was just this
kind of
shadow of living in tigers tiger's
shadow right now
phil is really coming to his own and he
seems to be enjoying it
and i you know i think all of us when we
start to see guys like rory and jt or
colin maracala
who are you know just these tiny guys
who
bomb it impossibly flexible it's nice to
see someone who looks a little bit more
like uh
us old folks of course at the same
weight look
i i love brady and tb12 and it looks
like aaron rodgers is on the ar12
and all that stuff but you know phil is
like i i
you know i i i can relate there because
you're talking about again when he was
dueling with tiger
back in the you know early aughts and i
was on sportscenter back then and we
were talking about tiger going on the
run and phil was the guy
who was the you know the greatest player
to not yet win a major and now he's a
guy
at age 50 who's the first 50 year old to
win a major
and i'm now inspired by the way he's
taking care of his body
you could knock me over with a feather
with that thing being
actually well i think we're gonna this
means we're gonna see you getting down
to around a four or five forty
yes it is really what i'm reading from
you no question
bingo if i show up next year if i show
up next year
all right at the if i show up next year
at the combine right or whenever
i'm gonna run it and i've got the george
hamilton tan and i got the shades on
you know i'm about to go torch it i'm
gonna torch it thumbs up
and torch it like thumbs up and point
and just
like the bonds like the fonts yeah
we will all vicariously feel the victory
rich when you do that
i appreciate that i do run for people i
i do run like phil
uh as a man of the people you know what
i mean that's the way i go about it
uh matt thanks for the time congrats on
season 13 holy cow
holy cow you're always very kind i i
really appreciate it it means a lot
oh my gosh thank you again my kids we
will be
we will be watching we will be watching
and then i'll be walking in like three
days later i'm like what the hell are
you doing
you've watched this 10 times already on
dvr
and honestly that is that is constantly
happening in my household kids they're
giving mad eisman job security and i
appreciate that oh my god
your plus seven rating from my kids
seven to twelve
uh they're personally they're personally
responsible for upping that plus seven
rating
thanks for the call matt you take care
of yourself always rich you got yeah
you bet that's matt iceman of uh of uh
american ninja warrior
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here